وانا احييكم مشاهدينا من جديد على الرغم
من انا تحالف المعارضه السداسيه في تركيا
انها اجتماعه الاخير في حضور قاده الاحزاب
السته بالاتفاق على العوده الى نظام الحكم
البرلماني حاله فوزها في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه والبرلمانيات التي ستعقد في 14
من مايو المقبل الا ان تلك الاحزاب التي
يقودها حزب الشعب الجمهوري وهو حزب
المعارضه الرئيسيه
سابقا في اجتماعاتها التي بلغ عددها حتى
الان احد عشر اجتماعا التحالف السداسي
مشاهدينا يسعى للاطاحه بالتحالف الحاكم
حاليا في تركيا والذي يضم حزبي العداله
والتنميه والحركه القوميه اليمنيه في
الانتخابات القادمه وحتى الان لم يقدم
التحالف السداسي مرشحا مشتركا عن
الاحزابلانكا
لمواجهه الرئيس التركي في الانتخابات
المقبله ووفقا للمراقبين تركيا فانه من
المنتظر ان يواجه اردوغان منافسه اقوى او
منافسين اقوياء اكدوا عزمهم على انهاء
حكمه
التي تم اعدادها في مطابخ الاحزاب
السياسيه السته التي تشكل تحالف الامه
المعروفه ايضا باسم مليتا والتي تتضمن
اهداف ملموسه واصلاحات وسياسات ومشاريعه
ومن شانها اخراج بلدنا من الازمه من اجل
نظام برلماني متحرر وديموقراطيل يضمن
الفصل بين السلطات بدلا من هذا النظام
الغريب الذي لا يعترف باي قواعد
ضيوفنا من اسطنبول
المحلله السياسي ومن اسطنبول
المحلله اساسي كذلك اهلا بكم
حالي ان ابدا مع الاستاذه جواد الاستاذ
جواد همم ما الذي يمكن ان يطرحه هذا
الائتلاف هذه المعارضه المشتركه لبعض يقول
بانها سداسيه قد
بالكرسي اردوغان هل هذا دقيق
التحالف السداسي هدفهم الاطاحه الى الرئيس
اردوغان في الانتخابات القادمه وهم يثقون
بانفسهم اكثر من السابق بالنتيجه همم كانت
هناك مشاكل في الانتخابات السابقه لكن في
الانتخابات الاخيره راينا انهم
فازوا في المدن الكبرى بالتحالف بعضهم مع
بعض طبعا هنا اصوات الاكراد مهمه جدا يعني
حزبوا شعوب الديمقراطيه بصراحه اذا كسبت
المعارضه اصوات اخواننا الاكراد في البلاد
بشكل عام قادرين ان يفوزون في الانتخابات
القادمه والا سوف يبقى الانتخابات الى
المرحله الثانيه وهناك سوف تكون منافسه
قويه جدا لكن
يثقون الى انفسهم اكثر من السادس
هناك منافسه قويه وجديه همم سيده اقطعي هل
توافق ضيفي على ان هذا التحالف الجديد
انصح التعبير قادر على ان يقف ندا بند
امام همم امام حزب حاكم في الواقع لم يخسر
لمده 15 عاما في كل الانتخابات التي دخلها
على امتداد عقدين
همم
نتفق مع الاستاذ جواد همم ان همم انه
ستكون في هذه المره تنافسنا قبيا سبعا كان
على مستوى الانتخابات الرئاسيه همم رئاسه
الجمهوريه او الانتخابات التشريعيه لان في
هذه المره كحالفت المعارضه كانت تدخل كل
حزب على حساب همم حسابه في هذه المره
تحالفات وتمثل هذه الاحزاب تقريبا كافه
الشرائح المجتمع التركي من اليمين الى
اليسار من من المحافظين الى لبراليا ولذلك
هناك فراس حقيقيه للفوز في هذه الانتخابات
بكل تاكيد اردوغان همم كاري
سياسيا كما انه يجيد المناورات السياسيه
وكذلك هو كذلك يقود التحالفا ااه حاكما
ولكن يعني حتى الان ان اا ال- ال-
جميع المؤشرات تؤكد همم اصول او اننا سنشد
تنافسان قويا والفرس تقريبا متساويه في
حال في حال تقطيم التحالف المعارض السداسي
المرشحا همم توافقيا قويا وكذلك في حال
الحفاظ على تماسكها
لانها تتشكل من احزاب مختلفه همم
لكل من همم منها ديولوجيا وخلفيه سياسيه
ممكن كان هناك مشروع موحد لهم وهذا مؤشر
اولي على ان هناك التفاف على الاقل همم
يعني نحو او حول مشروع واحد وهذا المشروع
قدموا فيه نقاط تخص السياسه داخليه
السياسه الخارجيه موضوع اللاجئين همم
تحدثوا حتى على تغيير خريطه السياسه في
تركيا سيد جواد يتحدثون عن العوده
للبرلمان بان يكون اقوى في السنوات
القادمه همم هل هذا يمكن ان يكون
نعم بدنا نتيجه النظام الرئاسي راينا انه
ليس لصالح بلدنا بصراحه يعني اعطاء
الصلاحيات الكبرى بهذا الشكل الى شخص واحد
يعني قد تسبب مشاكل عده كما راينا في
السياسات الخارجيه في العلاقات مع اوروبا
مع اشقائنا العربي وايضا سياسه داخليه كان
هناك ضغط بشكل
الاتفاق على اسقاط النظام الرئاسي
دي له الى النظام البرلمان فقط
ما رايك هل هم قادرون على ذلك اولا وثاليا
هل تتفق مع ضيفي بان النظام الرئاسي قد لا
يكون الامثل بالنسبه لتركيا ونظام برلماني
قوي قد يكون اصلح للبلد في السنوات
القادمه
لا يمكن القول ان النظام البرلماني
ديمقراطي والنظام
الرئاسه غير الديمقراطيه هناك دول مثل
الولايات المتحده همم
من اكبر الديمقراطيات كذلك فرنسا التي
تطبق شبه النظام شبه الرئاسي همم
ديمقراطه همم رغم انتقادنا لبعض السياستها
همم طبعا يعني العبره ليست في الشكل لان
النظام العبره في همم تطبيقها في الحقيقه
همم هناك اخطاء ونواقص في ان في همم في
النظام الرئاسي التركي لم يتم همم تشكيلها
وتركيبها بشكل جيد لا يشبه همم النظام همم
الرئاسي في الولايات المتحده ولا في فرنسا
بل تشبه الانظمه الرئاسيه المطلقه تقريبا
في الشرق الاوسط
كل الاساس بمعنى جمع صلاحيات في يد الرئيس
يعني اقتقد تشكل همم
مشاكل وصعوبات همم واحيانا همم
وكذلك همم عدم التفريق وتمييز المطلق بين
السلطات التنفيذيه والتشريعيه والقضائيه
همم
نعم هناك فرصه امام همم
المعارضه لتطبيق لان همم برنامج همم وضع
برنامج شاملا للاصلاح والتغيير
وانما تكمن في كيفيه تطبيقه تعليقك
طبعا نظام الرئاسه احد الانظمه الجيده في
العالم لكن لا يمشي في مثل بلادنا
يستغلون هذه
الفرصه يقدسون الشخص بشكل غريب جدا وغير
ذلك لا
مسائل عن ما فعله تقديس بشكل غريب جدا لكل
من ينتقده يعتبرون انه خيانه خونه للوطن
وغيره ذلك معنى اسم الشهيد ابراهيم تطرف
جدا في تقديس الشخصي نحن نريد ان نقضي
المؤسسات لاشخاص هذا هذه هي المشكله طبعا
المعارضه
يقول بانه الشكل مش هو الاولويه الاولويه
في كيفيه تطبيق هذا الشكل
راينا انه كانوا في التطبيق يعني غير
ناجحين بصراحه كان استطلاعات الشعبيه ترون
ان ان الشعب ليسوا راضين عن النظام
الرئاسي بهذا الشكل الموجود يعني محتواها
انه كل الامور بيد الشق الصواحد هذا خطا
يعني في مثل بلادنا يخفف من الديمقراطيه
بشكل عام نريد ان يكون هناك همم رئيس لكن
رئيس ااه فخري ان يكون القوه بيد البرلمان
وبيد الحكومه وبيد الرئيس الوزراء
بصلاحيات لكن صلاحياتها يكون محدوده ليست
كما ال ال ال اللي نرى في تركيا
براس فخري كما يقرا ضيف او يطمح على الاقل
هذا سيقرره الشعب التركي خلال هذه
الانتخابات هذه انتخابات رئاسيه
وتشريعيه لا لا تكفي للمعارضه للحصول على
الاغلبيه البسيطه اذا كانت حقيقه تريد
تغيير النظام ولا ندري هل هي جاده يعني
لان ربما عنده اذا فازت المعارضه وتمتلك
كل هذه الصلاحيات ربما تغير فكرها في
تغيير نظام همم شكل الاداره همم اذا همم
اذا كانت حقيقه تريد تغيير شكل الاداره
نظام الاداره عليه ان تفوز باغلبيه همم
نوعيه همم لان همم هذا الامر يحتاج هذا
الامر يتسلق صغيرا في الدستور والتغيير
يتطلب همم ولكن لماذا حضرتك
يعني
[موسيقى]
اذا كانت قلت ذلك لانه يحتاج الى العمل
الجديد العمل
والجهه الكبير جدا
وبموافقه الشعب التركي يعني حتى الان لم
تقدم مرشح توافقي
لا ندري هل
تتحافظ على تماسكها لم نرى حملتها
لانتخابيه يعني هناك امور كثيره همم
لفوز المعارضه بنفس الوقت طبعا اردوغان
كذلك سياسي ماهر همم وكذلك ستناوي
همم يعني عاطفا على كلام الاستاذ
هناك من همم
انتقد هذا التحالف جديد وكتبت احد الصحف
التركيه همم نخاف من ان يتم اخذ الجبل
فيلد فار انقل لك هذه العباره وهذا
التساؤل هل يمكن ان ارى طويله سداسيه
ياتيلاف قدم مشروع من نقاط عديده بتفاصيل
ولكن هل يمكن ان يتمخض فعلا الجبل ليلدرا
لاسقاته عن عيون الناس
في الانتخابات السابقه
للامور وكان هذا التحالف الجديد هو تحالف
في وجه في وجه اردوغان كشخص وليس في وجه
المنظومه الاداره محاوله لتغيير شيئا ما
طبعا ليه يقدمون شخص جديد ونفس جديد في
السياسه التركيه
صدقوني
عندما كان قبل رئيس بلديه اسطنبول لانه
شخص ملتزم ملائم جدا خطاباته ليست ناريه
ولهذا السبب جاؤوا
بالصوت يعني مليون فارق قريب من مليون
فارق من حزب الحلقات المحليه الان اذا
مثلا قدم منصور يا واش او حتى اكرم امام
اخذه رئيس بديل ممكن ان يفوزون بالسهوله
لكن هناك مخافه انه صلاحيات اخرى بهذا
الشكل
هؤلاء الاشخاص اللي ليس عنده بكافيه صعب
جدا امر المعارضه صعب لكن ما قالته الاولى
همم يعني في الانفص في الانتخابات القادمه
ربما نتابع مرحله جديده
16 جديده لاداخل السياسي التركي شكرا
جزيلا لكما على المشاركه وكل ما تفضلتم به
من اراء وتحاليل من اسطنبول جواد المحلل
السياسي ومن اسطنبول كذلك
المحلله السياسي شكرا لكم معا